- People were asking me
backstage, they're like, You
you've known her for a while.
And I was like, yes, I've
known her for a while.
- And now we have a song together
- We do. Me, you and Carly Pearce.
- Yeah, we do. It just came out.
- I can't actually tell
that full story on TV
but it's quite funny.
That recording day for me
- I asked Kelly to be a part
of my song in the morning
and she went to the studio
that night and did vocals.
- Wow.
- So you know what I'm gonna give you?
I'm gonna give you a little,
I'm gonna give you a little bit of it.
So she, I, it's my last day of work.
I have told Trisha, my
assistant in my group.
I'm like, I can't do anything.
- The day I texted you.
- The day you texted me,
I had literally been like,
Look this has to be on
this day then I'm off.
I was like, I promise myself this summer.
And not only you text me,
but Shane McInally our friend
who's also a singer songwriter.
And anyway, he, you both
texted me and they're like,
Oh, we got this song.
And I was like, Oh, I love Kelsey.
I was like, Okay, let
me just listen to it.
And I was like, I was like,
Oh, I have to do this.
Well,
I had already been celebrating.
- I do know this story.
- I had already been celebrating that
it was my last day of work.
Okay. So I, so I get to the
studio here at this studio
with Jason, and I get in
there and I'm like, Look
I didn't know I was
gonna be singing today.
I was like, I didn't know.
So I had to sing a song called
"You're Drunk, Go Home".
Inebriated, trying to sing for
soprano parts like I'm fine.
Like I, there is an actual full
track we have to send to you
of me just crying and laughing so hard.
I almost peed my pants.
- Please do.
- Cause I was like,
This has never happened to me in 20 years.
I've never ever been inebriated
while singing something.
And I am while singing,
You're, you're drunk, Go home.
- So there there is, there is this
- It's a great song, it's a great song.
- There's one ad lib
- I didn't know I had already
started and then you texted
- There's one part, um, on
the song where it's like um
an Ad lib Track and now
you're gonna hear it
and now you're gonna know
and you just hear Kelly go
"Um byeee."
And it's in there and it's cranked.
So thank you for that
- You're Welcome.
- Thank you for that.